[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen ihnen ein
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport als mentor von mir nach zwei
wochen krieg kommt möglicherweise etwas
bewegung in die politischen fronten
signale der gesprächsbereitschaft
hier drängt nicht länger auf
nato-mitgliedschaft moskau strebt nach
kreml aussagen keinen machtwechsel in
der ukraine an
die belagerte hauptstadt viele bewohner
versuchen kiew zu verlassen auf dem
majdan erklingt die europa haben
und bundesregierung billigt neues
infektionsschutzgesetz die meisten
bewohner maßnahmen entfallen in hotspots
können bundesländer aber schärfere
regeln beschließen
ein tag zwischen leiser hoffnung und
weiterem entsetzen erstmals kommen
kleine signale möglicher
kompromissbereitschaft von beiden
kriegsparteien
zudem scheinen die feuerpausen zur
evakuierung der menschen zumindest in
einigen fällen besser zu funktionieren
bei einem telefonat mit bundeskanzler
scholz warf russlands präsident putin
allerdings ukrainischen nationalisten
vor die evakuierungen immer wieder zu
sabotieren zugleich werden weitere
angriffe gemeldet auch auf die belagerte
hafenstadt mario pohl während der
waffenruhe volker check und tobias
häfner
der kriegsalltag macht auch nicht vor
dem kinderkrankenhaus halt alle fenster
geborsten der boden übersät mit trümmern
noch ist es zu früh um eine zahl der
opfer in mario pohl zu nennen zur
mittagszeit wenige kilometer entfernt es
gibt super aus regenwasser das von den
dächern aufgefangen wurde hier gibt es
kein trinkwasser mehr strom nur aus dem
generator täglicher beschuss durch die
russen
ohne wohnung und ohne medizin das rote
kreuz fragt wo es helfen kann meine
großmutter braucht unbedingt ihr herz
medikament sagt eine frau zum mann vom
roten kreuz
tausende zivilisten aus den belagerten
städten retten dafür plant die regierung
in kiew sechs flucht korridore die
eingeschlossenen sollen unter anderem
mario pohl verlassen auch in richtung
labor ist
sie uns bevölkerung soll noch lose war
abziehen können entlastung auch für die
einwohner so mies in richtung poltawa
ukraine
ist präsident see lenski ist sichtlich
bemüht kompromissbereitschaft zu zeigen
er sagt auf die frage des
us-amerikanischen moderators wenn also
der kreml von ihnen verlangt die pläne
für eine nato-mitgliedschaft fallen zu
lassen die krim aufzugeben und neu über
den status der separatisten gebiete zu
reden was würden sie dann tun
wir haben eine mögliche lösung für diese
drei punkte für die knackpunkte aber
putin muss bereit sein den dialog wieder
aufzunehmen
und wir als antwort betont das russische
außenministerium heute dass russland
weder die besatzung der ukraine noch den
sturz der aktuellen führung wolle vor
zwei wochen noch hatte putin gepoltert
sie lenski und seine regierung seien
eine bande neonazistischer
drogenabhängiger hier in der türkei
werden morgen jedenfalls die
außenminister von russland und der
ukraine tagen mit gedämpften erwartungen
auf beiden seiten
morgen also das erste treffen auf
regierungsebene in der türkei katrin
eigendorf ist das ein signal von
kompromissbereitschaft das
ist ein signal für
kompromissbereitschaft
wir sind hier in may lipsky
hier im hintergrund hört man werden
öffentlich jeden tag die nachrichten
durchgegeben die neuesten meldungen
die zeichen stehen darauf dass man an
den verhandlungstisch möglicherweise
kompromisse ausarbeiten will das haben
beide seiten signalisiert präsident see
lenski will entgegenkommen zeigen was
den status seines landes als
möglicherweise nicht nato mitglied und
praktisch neutrales land angeht aus
russischer seite von russischer seite
hören wir dass man möglicherweise über
die frage verhandeln will wie weit die
unabhängigkeit der ukraine gesichert ist
also entgegenkommen von beiden seiten
aber am boden hier heute weiter brutale
angriffe also da hat sich nichts
geändert an der brutalen strategie der
russen weiter zivilisten zu beschießen
und anzugreifen es wurde ja gerade im
beitrag der angriff auf das krankenhaus
auf die kinderklinik in mariupol genannt
und was auch sehr besorgniserregend ist
ist die lage um tschernobyl wie wir
hören gibt es von dort signale dass man
die lage dort nicht mehr wirklich im
griff hat und man auch den kontakt zur
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
verloren hat also das sind nachrichten
wie heute die leute doch sehr sehr
ängstlich machen wir in der ukraine
dankeschön katrin eigendorf live aus
meine ski im westen der ukraine
wir haben es gehört bei aller hoffnung
auf diplomatische fortschritte im moment
gehen die gefechte und das sterben
weiter viele berichte der kriegsparteien
sind nicht unabhängig zu überprüfen
auch weil kaum mehr reporter in den
umkämpften gebieten sind aus
sicherheitsgründen
eine der wenigen ist der freie
journalist und gänze erst seit gestern
in kiel hier seine eindrücke aus der
belagerten hauptstadt
wir sind unterwegs in kiew unterwegs in
einer stadt die sich abschottet so gut
es geht es herrscht eine gespenstische
ruhe die immer wieder durchbrochen wird
das
das bedeutet ist es
wieder luftalarm
geräusch was man sehr häufig
wir fahren in eine siedlung nur zwei
kilometer vom zentrum entfernt
david lebt in der nachbarschaft und
zeigt uns was hier am zweiten kriegstag
passiert ist das wohnhaus ist bei einem
luftangriff getroffen worden
sind ja in einem neuen blog in kiew und
hier sieht man mal die schäden die diese
raketen hinterlassen selbst wenn sie in
der luft zerstört werden hier sind
trümmerteile einer rakete eingeschlagen
das ganze hat das leben von zwei
menschen gekostet präsent diese
zerstörungen vor denen tausende fliehen
andere aber bleiben um zu helfen
natalias tariq opfer versorgt menschen
die sich in den u-bahnhöfen verschanzt
haben mit warmem essen
natürlich ist das gefährlich aber wenn
wir arbeiten denken wir wenigstens nicht
daran was hier passieren könnte
vor einer apotheke wartet maria auf
medikamente nicht für sich sondern für
verletzte soldaten wir fragen sie ob sie
in kiew bleiben will
ja ich will den anderen menschen hier
einfach nur helfen
[Musik]
und dann erklingt mitten in der stadt
plötzlich musik auf dem majdan dem platz
der unabhängigkeit spielt das klassische
orchester von kiew beethovens neunte die
europahymne sie spielen an gegen die
stille und gegen die angst
[Musik]
der russische angriff auf die ukraine
wird auch in finnland mit großer sorge
beobachtet das nordeuropäische land mit
5,5 millionen einwohnern hat von allen
eu-mitgliedern die längste grenze mit
russland mehr als 1300 kilometer
die finnen sind nicht in der nato doch
mit blick auf den nachbarn wollen sie
nun militärisch aufstocken klaas
thomssen und heike kruse berichten
sie üben krieg mitten auf dem flughafen
von helsinki reservisten berufssoldaten
und wehrpflichtige gemeinsame manöver
seit jahrzehnten finden solche übungen
überall in finnland zweimal jährlich
statt der russische angriff auf die
ukraine hat sie nachdenklich gemacht
ist es möglich dass das hier auch in
finnland passiert nun ist es gerade sehr
ruhig in nordeuropa grauen hoffen wir
dass das so bleibt
die finden sind den starken nachbarn
russland gewöhnt kein nato mitglied zu
sein war bislang die beste friedens
garantie laut umfragen können sich nun
immer mehr finden einen nato-beitritt
irgendwann vorstellen denn die angst
wird größer ein not too much more the
board ich bin zwar nicht allzu besorgt
was eine invasion oder so etwas
ähnliches angeht aber
natürlich lässt einen die
rücksichtslosigkeit russlands ins
grübeln kommen
ist es wirklich so schwer zu glauben
dass russland uns auch an heißen würde
es ist schon beängstigend
grenzübergang war lima im südosten alles
normal aber dass keine flüge aus
russland in richtung westen mehr gibt
nehmen die einreise auf dem landweg zu
normalerweise bekommen wir von einem
russen pro monat ein asylgesuch monat
nun ist es hier inzwischen 1 jeden tag
am hauptbahnhof helsinki ist für zwei
züge aus sankt petersburg täglich in
station viele menschen bleiben aber
nicht in finnland sondern fahren zum
flughafen sie wollen noch weiter weg von
putins russland
bis zu 22 millionen menschen sind
mittlerweile aus der ukraine geflohen
sagt die uno und ein ende des exodus
seien nicht abzusehen auch hier in
deutschland kommen immer mehr menschen
an die behörden haben jetzt etwa 80.000
gezählt tatsächlich dürften es deutlich
mehr sein in den bundesländern geht es
jetzt darum die geflüchteten erst einmal
zu versorgen und unterzubringen die
bereitschaft zu helfen ist groß allein
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
sind bislang 81 millionen euro
zusammengekommen wenn auch sie spenden
wollen die kontonummer des
aktionsbündnisses lautet bahn.de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
nothilfe ukraine alle infos auch unter
spenden zdf.de oder im zdf text auf
seite 8 190 von der bischofskonferenz
gab es heute viel lob für polen und
seine große hilfsbereitschaft für die
flüchtlinge auf ihrer
frühjahrsvollversammlung in bayern
verurteilten die bischöfe die russische
invasion als völkerrechtswidrigen
angriff die ukraine habe ein recht auf
selbstverteidigung
waffenlieferungen seien mit der
christlichen friedens lehre vereinbar
auch heute gibt es ein zdf spezial zu
den entwicklungen in ukraine krieg
gleich nach dieser sendung
hintergrundinformationen über mögliche
zugeständnisse russlands und der ukraine
und welche bedingungen sie daran knüpfen
finden sie in unserer der f heute
auch corona beschäftigt uns weiter da
hat die bundesregierung einen fahrplan
auf den weg gebracht nachdem viele
beschränkungen wegfallen und zwar ab dem
20 märz dann soll das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz in kraft treten
allerdings steigen die zahlen seit einer
woche wieder das rk ii meldet heute eine
7 tage incidents von
1319 und 314 neue todesfälle was das für
mögliche lockerungen bedeutet britta
buchholz
garmisch partenkirchen in bayern hat im
winter einen traurigen rekord gebrochen
die höchste sieben tage incidents
deutschlands ein sogenannter hotspot
erst die skisaison dann karneval
vielerorts sind die zahlen hoch dennoch
fallen in zehn tagen fast alle coroner
regeln weg der gesundheits und der
justizminister stellen nun einen
notfallplan vor wenn wir eine besondere
gefahrensituation haben die wir auch
sauber rechtsstaatlich definieren müssen
dann muss es auch mehr maßnahmen geben
können und genau das leistet die hotspot
regelung doch nicht nur in hotspots
können maßnahmen wie 2g oder 3g wieder
eingeführt werden sobald eine hohe
inzidenz oder eine gefährliche corona
variante da ist können regional
schärfere regeln kommen neu ist darüber
entscheiden die länderparlamente im
blick auch pflegeheime und krankenhäuser
da immer noch zehn prozent der älteren
nicht geimpft sind sollen besonders
gefährdete gruppen mit sogenannten basis
maßnahmen geschützt werden die
basismaßnahmen sind im wesentlichen
masken und testen das betrifft die
sogenannten wollen arabien gruppen zum
beispiel menschen die in
pflegeeinrichtungen betreut werden von
ambulanten pflegediensten versorgt
werden oder in krankenhäusern versorgt
werden der fdp justizminister wollte
keine noch härteren maßnahmen
anders als der spd gesundheitsminister
das kabinett hat dem kompromiss bereits
zugestimmt von einigen
ministerpräsidenten kommt aber bereits
kritik zeitnah beraten darüber bundestag
und bundesrat
österreich hatte als erstes eu-land eine
allgemeine impfpflicht beschlossen sie
gilt seit februar jetzt die kehrtwende
die impfpflicht wird ausgesetzt
angesichts der infektions lage derzeit
sei sie nicht mehr verhältnismäßig sagt
die regierung in drei monaten will man
erneut über die impfpflicht entscheiden
es ist die gute nachricht für die
menschen im osten australiens der
wochenlange regen ist vorbei doch jetzt
wird klar was viele verloren haben sie
räumen ihre häuser aus möbel
erinnerungsstücke alles müll und es
stellt sich die frage wie das leben
weitergeht auf einem kontinent den der
klimawandel dramatisch trifft normen
odenthal es dort
als john das wasser bis zum hals stand
stand er selbst im dachgeschoss von dort
oben aus dem fenster zeigt er uns hatten
ein bord gerettet sein hab und gut
völlig unter wasser
alles ist weg wir müssen von tag zu tag
sehen es weitergeht
zwei tage jetzt endlich ohne regen im
disco nach endlos nassen wochen aufholen
wenn man das im fernsehen sieht denkt
man ja das ist schlimm aber dass selbst
zu sehen zu spüren der gestand das
gerümpel dieses enorme ausmaß straße für
straße endlos
die ganze stadt ein trümmerfeld
verlorene existenzen stapeln sich am
straßenrand die bürger helfen sich
selbst in großer solidarität wird
gespendet angepackt der hilfe geld
einsatzkräfte verspricht heute der
premier und ruft dafür den nationalen
notstand aus
dieser teil australiens hat so eine flut
seit menschengedenken nicht erlebt nie
wurde so etwas aufgezeichnet das ist
eine aussage die man nicht meist fertig
trifft mir wurde gesagt so etwas kommt
alle 500 jahre
proteste heute in lismore da hat sich
etwas aufgestaut
das wasser geht die politiker kommen und
werden ihren dispo nicht gerade
freundlich empfangen viele leute sind
ärgerlich wollen echte hilfe statt
versprechen und viele leute das sagen
sie uns wollen auch endlich dass das
thema klimawandel in der australischen
politik ernst genommen wird
angesichts solcher katastrophen werde es
schwieriger in australien zu leben sagt
der premier heute noch kein widerspruch
dafür
und dann gilt es noch abschied zu nehmen
von einer die nicht müde wurde mit ihrer
geschichte wach zu rütteln die
holocaust-überlebende inge deutschkron
als junge frau konnte sie sich mit ihrer
mutter in berlin vor den nazis
verstecken später engagierte sie sich
als journalistin und autorin um ihre
erfahrungen zu vermitteln zum beispiel
in einer bewegenden rede 2013 im
bundestag und immer wieder an schulen
eine deutsch krone wurde 99 jahre alt
ja es geht es weiter mit norbert und den
parallel dass zwei weitere deutsche
medaillen wieder im langlauf diesmal im
freistil-sprint bei den see
beeinträchtigten frauen gewinnt lind
katzmaier bronze das ist schon ihre
dritte medaille in peking und marco
meyer der hut sein zweites silber
marco meier vorne behauptet sich im
sulzigen schnee an der steigung und
verteidigt auf der zielgeraden seinen
zweiten platz hinter dem franzosen jean
daniel aber knapp vor gregory wurfchance
key aus der ukraine
ich dachte jetzt kannst du jetzt
irgendwann mal die zielgerade es hat
gereicht zwar recht eng covered gereicht
erneut hat der 22-jährige student im
sprint überrascht nimmt katzmaier die 15
jährige schülerin aus freiburg schafft
es auch beim massenstart auf das podest
mit ihrem guide florian baumann erkämpft
sie ihre dritte medaille bronze für
katzmaier hinter der österreicherin
edlinger und der ukrainerin schiff
koffer
zur fußball-champions-league da haben
sich jürgen klopp und sein fc liverpool
ins viertelfinale gezittert 0 zu 1
-heimniederlage gestern abend gegen
inter aber das reichte den reds fürs
weiterkommen dank ihres 20 0
hinspielsiegs in mailand ja
gala-vorstellung dagegen des fcb allen
voran von robert lewandowski mit 7 zu 1
fertigte münchen abi salzburg im
achtelfinal rückspiel ab bayerns rekord
torschützenkönig der rekordtorschütze
mit einer historischen hattrick show
der arbeitsnachweis von robert
lewandowski liest sich wie ein
fußballmärchen zwei tore durch an ihm
verschuldete und selbst verwandelte
foulelfmeter und nach nur 23 minuten
sein dritter treffer das alles erneuert
champions league rekordzeit
und noch vor der halbzeit lädt sabri mit
dem 4 0 zum pausengetränk 1 wir waren ja
sehr gierig auf dem platz hat eine gute
energie und haben völlig verdient gegen
ohnmächtige salzburger machen die bayern
durch zweimal thomas müller und durch
den schlusspunkt zum 7 zu 1 von nissan
bis zum ende weiter und stehen nach
diesem fußballerisches feuerwerk zum
zwanzigsten mal im viertelfinale der
champions league
ja und die highlights der achtelfinal ko
spiele von gestern und heute zu sehen
bei uns im sportstudio champions league
23 uhr
tolles wetter heute im rhein-main-gebiet
lohnte der blick nach oben
kunstflugpiloten haben dort ihre
botschaft hinterlassen und zwar in
großbuchstaben stop the board und
frieden in deutscher englischer und
russischer sprache
und jetzt noch die lottozahlen lauten
8 18 19 28 36 38 und die superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
und das wetter beschert uns weiter viel
sonne die details hat gleich als den
termin das heute journal mit christian
sievers beginnt kurz vor 10 hier geht es
gleich weiter mit dem zdf spezial und
morgen begrüßt sich hier jana bereichs
danke für ihr interesse alles gute hin
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nach gut zwei
wochen hohem luftdruck haben wir das
nächste hoch dass wir bis 2040
hektopascal erreichen ein sehr starkes
hoch auf seiner ostseite kommt eisige
luft bis in die türkei runter und bei
uns deutlich mildere und so werden
morgen bis zu 16 grad erreicht in der
nacht klart es verbreitet auf etwas
bewirken gibt's richtung ostsee und das
bei tiefsten temperaturen von minus
sieben grad an den alpen minus fünf grad
im osten und plus ein grad nach westen
hin morgen dann viel sonnenschein nur im
osten gibt es einige harmlose wolken
insgesamt weiterhin trockenes wetter bei
höchsten temperaturen von sieben grad an
der ostsee und 16 grad im westen aber
schauen sie mal in der westhälfte werte
zwischen 12 und 15 grad die nächsten
tage bleiben größtenteils sonnig am
freitag 6 bis 15 grad und insgesamt
ändert sich wenig damit ein schöner
abend